[Music]
you remember the dream i spoke of you
sailed through helheim on a ship of fire
here it may come to pass
dreams
life
maybe they are one and the same
wow
[Music]
tonight i ride the flaming sea street
rushing for the spear day
i watch her light from water's wake
another glory
ready yourselves ruined [__] stains will
see us coming
[Music]
we bring helheim to our enemies
how nice they greet us with some of
their own from the air
arrows
close one that was
honor yourself
[Music]
for impact
bye
go
[Applause]
so
prepare to cut them down
oh
sick
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
to the gate and push and keep pushing
east anglia depends on it
fights
yes
[Music]
aah
that's it
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
wow
oswald
he lives
oswald lives evil is that you
shut your ass twigspine
stun fast this will be over soon worry
not for me you must stop silence fool
so this is what it comes to wolf kissed
two danes fighting over a filthy saxon
[__] son
if this swine is your prize
come and get him
valdis
you choose them
uh
keep the boats
[Music]
going to summer
give me strength
[Music]
yes
you are finished here
you must be blind to stand with such a
man
fighting for a saxon king
come to dine
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
for all your efforts only the cold dark
of niflheim awaits you
you're better than this than all of them
do not drag me down to the sewage you
wallow in
lead
[Music]
thank you
you'd throw in with these wastrels
these are swine
for what a scribe of land and a promise
of peace evil no
he should be tried before god a lawful
assembly
i won't have my reign begin with more
blood spilt than is needed
he deserves death oswalt that is our way
evil please
blood for blood leaves no warmth in the
hearts of men evil none at all
[Music]
i should speak with oswalt
see if he is well
[Applause]
saxon and dane we fought well side by
side
if there is to be a future for both our
kind people like you and me will have to
change the most to live within it
even if that makes us
uneasy
when you're a crown king the laws of
this land will be yours to decide
all this is
is like a dream
but you are not asleep
well fought well fought the both of you
you came as well old friend
if i'd known you was still alive i would
have stayed in norwich
look around you a happy occasion and a
glorious victory
and soon something more grand to take
place
our wedding my love
if you will still have me that is and
why would i not
i fought poorly i melted under the heat
and anger of that brute
and i never thought stop
you fought with all your heart and soul
that's all you need ever do
come then
we have much to prepare for
a bride to wed in a kingdom to lead what
some men wouldn't give for such things
countless men have died for them and you
finish are you jealous of such things
hardly my heart is a fire but my body
aches
i desire only a long nap
i saw a bale of hay back there
later abel
for now i must see to the wounded then i
will see you at the wedding hi of course
you will
i should return to elmanham oscar's
wedding will soon begin
you